auch das siebte mal heute ja
ausnahmsweise donnerstagmorgen in berlin
feiertag ist so macht dabei haben heute
mit professor lars schaade vizepräsident
des robert-koch-instituts sehr schade
bitte ja guten morgen meine damen und
herren ich möchte zunächst beginnen mit
einem kurzen überblick über die
internationale situation die länder mit
den höchsten gemeldeten und berichteten
fallzahlen sind die vereinigten staaten
mit 1,2 millionen fällen 73.000 gebäudes
fällen spanien mit 219 1300 berichteten
fällen darunter 25.600 todesfällen
italien mit 213.000 berichteten verein
und 29.300 todesfällen
das war einigte königreich mit 195.000
fällen und 29.400 berichteten
todesfällen die russische föderation mit
155 1400 berichteten fällen und 1500
todesfällen mittlerweile sind mehr als
3,5 millionen fälle weltweit bekannt und
berichtet worden
nahezu alle länder berichten fälle und
auch weiterhin ist der schwerpunkt der
unter den berichteten fällen das
ausbruchsgeschehen weiterhin nordamerika
und europa zur epidemiologischen
situation in deutschland
in deutschland wurden bis heute 1166
1091 kur wird 19 fälle übermittelt das
sind 1284 mehr als am vortag
darunter waren bislang 7000 119
todesfälle
das sind 123 todesfälle mehr als am
vortag
die gesamt incidents beträgt 200 fälle
pro 100.000 einwohner und in dieser
woche wurden an den tagen etwas
unterschiedlich fälle übermittelt
das waren zwischen 700 und 1300 fällen
die pro tag übermittelt worden
die zahl der gelesenen schätzen wir auf
139 1900 die produktionszahl r schätzen
wir mit stand von gestern auf 0,65
und die fallzahlen können sie auch
täglich nachlesen oder nachlesen mit der
täglichen aktualisierung auf unserem
dashboard zugänglich über unsere corona
website
es gibt auch zusätzlich jeden tag einen
situationsbericht mit einer
lageeinschätzung und weiteren details
den über unsere website abrufen können
einige details zu den fällen in
deutschland die betroffenen personen
sind im schnitt 50 jahre alt männer und
frauen sind etwa gleichermaßen betroffen
rund vier fünftel der übermittelten
fälle liegen rund vier fünftel der
übermittelten fälle liegen klinische
informationen vor
häufig genannte symptome sind husten 50%
viebahn 41% schnupfen symptomatik in 21
prozent und in etwa 15 prozent
max und geruchs verlust für 18 prozent
der fälle wurde eine hospitalisierung
übermittelt das entspricht rund 23.000
900 fällen
von den 136 1000 fällen mit
ausreichenden angaben dazu und für 2,8
prozent der fälle ist bekannt dass sie
eine lungenentzündung oder pneumonie
entwickelt haben der anteil der
verstorbenen diese 7119 personen der
anteil der verstorbenen unter den
gemeldeten fällen beträgt 4,3 prozent
dieser anteil der verstorbenen unter den
gemeldeten fällen ist damit weiterhin
recht hoch
das licht weiterhin auch daran dass
immer noch ausbrüche in alters und
pflegeheimen und krankenhäusern zu
verzeichnen sind wo eben besonders viele
risikogruppen betroffen sind
zudem sehen wir aber auch generell viele
erkrankungsfälle unter älteren menschen
es befinden sich noch viele kurven 19
fälle in stationärer behandlung und wir
müssen daher leider auch mit einem
weiteren anstieg der todesfälle rechnen
die verstorbenen personen waren im
durchschnitt 81 jahre alt 87 prozent der
verstorbenen personen waren 70 jahre
oder älter
wir hatten in den letzten wochen immer
wieder die drei säulen der kuh wird 19
aufbruchs bekämpfung betont erstens wir
müssen das virus eindämmen
zweitens wir müssen besonders gefährdete
gruppen schützen
drittens wir müssen ausreichende
kapazitäten aufbauen und vorhalten das
gilt für die tests genauso wie in den
krankenhäusern und im öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienst all diese punkte
bleiben weiterhin zentral im weiteren
umgang mit cupid 19
das ziel ist weiterhin die fallzahlen so
niedrig wie möglich zu halten damit so
wenig wie möglich menschen erkranken
das erreichen wir einerseits gemeinsam
durch das bereits oft zitierte und
erwähnte abstand halten und das
einhalten der hygieneregeln um die dauer
fallzahlen dauerhaft niedrig zu halten
ist es aber auch weiter essenziell dass
die arbeit der gesundheitsämter eben vor
ort geschieht und diese wichtige arbeit
der gesundheitsämter
sie haben die fälle vor ort im blick es
ist ihre aufgabe fälle zu identifizieren
zu isolieren dann die kontaktperson zu
identifizieren und enge kontakte
daneben unter quarantäne zu stellen sie
entscheiden über die maßnahmen in
bestimmten settings wie zum beispiel
auch ausbrüchen in altenheim
nur so kann man die infektionsketten
unterbrechen nur so kann man verhindern
dass sich das virus weiter verbreitet
all das machen die mitarbeiterinnen
mitarbeiter der gesundheitsämter vor ort
das ist besonders in zeiten wie diesen
eine sehr aufwändige und
verantwortungsvolle arbeit und sie ist
zentral für die ausbruchs bekämpfung
wir wissen dass viele gesundheitsämter
praktisch rund um die uhr im einsatz
sind
daher möchte ich meine ich mich bei den
gesundheitsämtern im namen des gesamten
energie ganz herzlich bedanken
das rk ii unterstützt den öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienst auf verschiedene
weisen und auf verschiedenen ebenen als
ein beispiel möchte ich nennen dass wir
sogenannte containment scouts ausbilden
die dann vor ort die gesundheitsämter
unterstützen zb bei der kontaktpersonen
nachverfolgung bislang sind bundesweit
bereits 350 350 containment scouts in
den
so und hals ämtern tätig insgesamt
sollen es 500 werden die wir ausbilden
und dann den gesundheitsämtern zur
unterstützung zur verfügung stellen
zum schluss noch ein hinweis in eigener
sache ab der kommenden woche wird es
keine regelmäßigen pressebriefing zum
robert-koch-institut mehr geben
zu beginn der epidemie war es besonders
wichtig regelmäßig über die situation in
deutschland zu informieren und das
geschehen einzuordnen
die situation war sehr dynamisch anfangs
haben wir sogar jeden werktag ein
briefing durchgeführt das hat sich
inzwischen geändert die fallzahlen gegen
glücklicherweise seit längerer zeit
zurück wir stehen natürlich auch weiter
für presseanfragen zur verfügung und wir
werden auch wieder presse briefings
anbieten aber anlassbezogen nicht mehr
regelmäßig natürlich finden sie unsere
neuigkeiten die informationen zu
fallzahlen zu epidemiologie die
lageberichte weiterhin auf unserer
website www rk ii.de schnitt 19 zimmer
oder auch auf unseren dashboard und dem
situationsbericht beides wird täglich
aktualisiert und ich weiß dass auch
viele bürger zu schauen und sie möchte
ich zusätzlich auf die bürgerinformation
der bundeszentrale für gesundheitliche
aufklärung hinweisen
wir behalten unseren presseverteiler zu
kugelt 19 wir pflegen diesen verteiler
weiter und wir informieren sie über den
verteiler zeitnah über neuigkeiten an
dieser stelle ganz herzlichen dank an
alle journalisten die so regelmäßig bei
uns zu besuch waren zuerst im hörsaal
und dann virtuell und natürlich auch an
alle zuschauer
ich freue mich jetzt auf ihre fragen
vielen dank vielen dank
schade wir gehen direkt zu a&p frank
jordans
ja danke ganz zu ihrem kontinent scouts
hätte ich gerne fragen sie sagen wie
viele personen zusätzlich zu wesen
containment scouts ungefähr an der
nachverfolgung von beteiligt sind und
gibt es eine große zahl die man lieber
schweigen kann wie viele stunden es
ungefähr braucht um so einen fall
[Musik]
nachzuverfolgen nur damit man die
dimensionen dieser arbeiten besser
verstehen ja also zu diesmal gibt's
natürlich die grundausstattung der
gesundheitsämter die haben ja schon
immer auch kontaktpersonen
nachverfolgung gemacht die ist natürlich
da nach meinem kenntnisstand sind die
gesundheitsämter auch weiter verstärkt
worden aus anderen bereichen der
verwaltung da kann ich ihnen aber nicht
sagen
keine zahlen nennen absolute zahlen sind
da glaube ich auch nicht so zielführend
weil die gesundheitsämter hat auch eine
sehr unterschiedliche größe haben
in großstädten gibt es recht großer
ämter in kleineren landkreisen und dass
er dann gibt es eben nicht so viel
personal war prozentual kann ich ihnen
das nicht nennen
ich kann ihnen nur sagen dass wir eben
von unserer seite 500 personen
zusätzlich beitragen und dass es eben
auch auf politischer ebene beschlüsse
gibt hier auch aus den ländern weiteres
personal letztendlich in die
gesundheitsämter zu geben und personell
zu verstärken
zur dauer der kontaktperson
nachverfolgung auch das ist sehr
variabel
wir wissen dass es eben teilweise fälle
gibt die nur fünf kontakte haben oder
kontaktpersonen häufiger sind auch zehn
bis zwanzig aber dann gibt es eben auch
zum beispiel im rahmen von größeren
ereignissen oder
irgendwelchen beengten verhältnissen wie
zum beispiel auf schiffen da gibt es
dann eben auch sehr viele
kontaktpersonen und da ist das natürlich
dann aufwendiger das kann schon mal
viele stunden dauern oder auch mehrere
tage aber eine exakte zahl kann ich
ihnen nicht sagen tut mir leid
wir gehen zu frau ludwig von der
süddeutschen zeitung
von ludwig ii hören sie mich ja erstmal
wie das nun zustande kommt die
entscheidung dass sie die presse
briefings jetzt einstellen
ist es nicht so dass durch die
regionalisierung der maßnahmen jetzt
eher unsicherheiten in den verlauf der
epidemie com und es dadurch eher mehr
bedarf gibt die lage einzuordnen auch
für die öffentlichkeit und zweite frage
wäre die sie denn jetzt einzelne sehr
weitgehende maßnahmen werden
als beispiel für dich nennen die öffnung
der schwimmbäder in nrw oder die es
erlauben von veranstaltungen mit bis zu
100 leuten in hessen
ja also zunächst mal gibt es ja mehrere
gründe warum wir das jetzt einstellen
die regelmäßigen presse briefings wir
haben eben sinkende fallzahlen
es gibt eine neue phase in dieser in
dieser epidemie so gesehen
gesellschaftlich auch gesehen dass wir
jetzt eine öffnung versuchen das ist ja
ganz richtig das bedeutet aber eben auch
eine sage ich meine schlagwort ist ja
häufiger gefallen auch eine neue
normalität in einen gesellschaftlichen
bereichen
und das bedeutet eben auch dass wir dann
wieder uns entschieden haben auf die
übliche pressearbeit umzustellen und
eben die täglichen regelmäßigen presse
briefings einzustellen wenn es
letztendlich zur entwicklung kommt die
dazu führt dass wir entsprechende
informationen für sie haben dann werden
wir auch entsprechend wie der presse
briefings anlassbezogen durchführen das
hatte ich ja gesagt
und die regionalisierung ist natürlich
auch eben ein anlass wir können eben
auch nicht alle fragen auf bundesebene
beantworten die letztendlich auf
landesebene entschieden werden was
maßnahmen angeht und ähnliches auch auf
was die entwicklung auf landesebene
angeht und sicher ist es dann auch
erforderlich dass man eben dort vor ort
dort wo die entscheidungen getroffen
werden wo das monitoring dann gemacht
wird für diese regionalen entscheidungen
und maßnahmen dann dort die frage
gestellt wir können ja nicht für die
länder diese fragen alle beantwortet und
in diesem sinne möchte ich auch die
nächste frage von ihnen beantworten
all diese maßnahmen die jetzt gelockert
werden köln auf verschiedener ebene
das muss mit augenmaß gemacht werden das
ist auch gesagt worden ja gestern bei
den politischen beschlüssen all das muss
unter einhaltung von hygienemaßnahmen
durchgeführt werden möglichst auch unter
dem motto unter der maßgabe des abstand
halten
nur dann wird es erfolgreich sein ohne
dass die fallzahlen wieder steigen und
in diesem sinne kann man letztendlich
jede maßnahme betrachten alle maßnahmen
bergen ein gewisses risiko das ist auch
von politischer seite ja durchaus so
auch formuliert worden
damit wir sind wir nicht in sicherheit
mit dieser neuen phase
es ist eine entscheidung hier zu einer
weiteren öffnung zu kommen die
sicherlich unter der beachtung der
gesamtgesellschaftlichen aspekte auch
durchaus nachvollziehbar ist und die
vielen kleinen schritte müssen dann eben
trotz der regionalisierung weiterhin
vorsichtig gemacht werden und weiterhin
mit den entsprechenden flankierenden
vorkehrungen was sie gene und abstand
regeln angeht
mehr kann ich ihnen da zurzeit so nicht
sagen
in den ländern
einzelne institute die vergleichbar
werden mit dem echten das ist
unterschiedlich geregelt in den ländern
in der regel sind auf jeden fall die
natürlich die gesundheitsministerium die
obersten landesgesundheitsbehörden und
einige länder haben eben auch ähnliche
institute wie das robert-koch-institut
auf der landesebene aber
alle das muss man dann von land zu land
sich anschauen
wir gehen zu dpa afx roschinski locken
ich habe eine frage zu den risikogruppen
also den bauanträgen und älteren können
denn jetzt kinder und jugendliche ihre
großeltern wieder ohne bedenken besuchen
oder was müssen sie da erwarte also
grundsätzlich gelten natürlich weiterhin
die die empfehlung dass das diese person
besonders geschützt werden müssen
das heißt beginnt mit denen mit den ganz
normalen hygieneempfehlungen dass man
eben händewaschen oder händedesinfektion
bevor man dorthin geht zum zum besuch
dass man möglichst auch einen mundschutz
auf jeden fall tragen sollte und so wie
ich das verstanden habe die beschlüsse
von gestern sollen eben nur ein
beschränkter personenkreis eben diese
person die die älteren personen und die
risikogruppen dann besuchen können
wie das genau gestaltet wird das wird
sicherlich jetzt jedes land wieder in
einer eigenen verordnung festlegen da
kann ich in details nicht nennen aber so
wie ich es verstanden habe ist das ein
eingeschränkter personenkreis und
bedeutet nicht dass jetzt jeder wieder
frei letztendlich zum besuch zu diesen
risikogruppen in entsprechenden
gemeinschaftseinrichtungen gehen kann
vielen dank
wir gehen zum ndr herr maßen vermaßen
wir maßen ist noch nicht bereit wir
probieren es gleich nochmal er will man
von der welt guten tag frau will man ich
hoffe sie hören mich auch immer die
frage nach den neuinfektionen auch in
den landkreisen diese zahl 50 in einer
woche pro 100000 einwohner ist ja jetzt
offenbar so die marke an der auch
festgemacht wird ob es zu weiteren
lockerungen oder doch wieder
verschärfungen kommt mich würde mal
interessieren inwiefern war man da als
robert koch-institut involviert bei der
gestaltung dieser marke und wie ja
wichtig halten sie die rauch- oder wie
richtig justiert sehen sie die auch wie
wirksam ist das als quasi ein tool für
die zukunft um das immer dann
entscheiden zu können
ja also das robert koch institut ist
natürlich bei den beratungen über die in
frage kommenden optionen welche
indikatoren kann man da wählen beteiligt
gewesen
an der entscheidung selbst ist das
robert koch institut nicht beteiligt
gewesen
das ist welcher maßgabe dann
letztendlich angelegt wird oder welcher
maßstab das ist eine entscheidung der
politik ganz generell möchte ich sagen
das ist ein pragmatischer grenzwert den
ich auch grundsätzlich für sinnvoll
halte eine verständliche kennzahl ist
glaube ich wichtig als grenzwert um eine
bestimmte eskalationsstufe neu zu
starten um letztendlich das von der
lokalen ebene unterscheiden ja auch ein
wesentlicher punkt zu sein von der
entscheidungshoheit der rein lokalen
ebene dann auf die nächst höhere ebene
auf die landesebene zu heben was
entscheidungen künftiger maßnahmen
angeht
ergänzend ist es aber und das ist mir
wichtig an diesem punkt zu sagen auch
geübte praxis dass die gesundheitsämter
vor ort eine situation umfassend
bewerten und dann über die
erforderlichen maßnahmen entscheiden
das bedeutet eben wie schon
erwähnt kontaktsuche quarantäne
isolierung also all das wird natürlich
weiter laufen völlig unabhängig von
diesem jahr in anführungszeichen
grenzwert von 50 neuinfektionen pro
100.000 einwohner und dann nochmal ganz
klar zu sagen jedes jeder landkreis der
hat ein gesundheitsamt und diese
gesundheitsämter gehen jedem einzelnen
fall nach jeder einzelne fall ist
meldepflichtig und jeder einzelne fall
führt zu einer aktivität des
gesundheitsamtes die darauf abzielt
diesen kranken zu isolieren und seine
kontakte zu identifizieren unter
quarantäne zu stellen
das wird auf jeden fall immer passieren
auch völlig unabhängig von dieser zahl
50 neue infektionen pro 100 1000
einwohner
nach meinem verständnis dient diese zahl
eben dafür letztendlich eine nächst
höhere entscheidungsebene einzubeziehen
und ein konzept zu entwickeln wie man
denn weitergehende an die epidemische
maßnahmen auf bevölkerungs ebene
einführen will wenn dieses geschehen ein
etwas größeres ausmaß annimmt
vielen dank
wir probieren es nochmal der kollege ist
verschwunden
wir gehen zur taz herr kreutzfeldt ja
schon guten morgen als erstes keine
frage sondern eine anmerkung sind das
nicht nachvollziehbar und absolut falsch
dass sie die täglichen sie die
regelmäßigen presse briefings einstellen
wollen ich finde man sieht an der zahl
der fragen hergestellt werden an der
zahl der medien alle großen medien sie
hier teilnehmen die offensichtlichen
informationsbedarf haben es ist diesen
informationsbedarf gibt ich finde das
nicht nachvollziehbar und wüsste gern
als erstes stadtmann inhaltlichen frage
wer das nun eigentlich entschieden hat
war dass die leitung des akg oder ist
das ein gutes des ministeriums dass
diese presse briefings eingestellt
werden das ist eine entscheidung der
leitung des robert koch instituts und
gibt es die möglichkeit dass sie diese
entscheidung revidieren wenn ihnen die
medien mitteilen oder sie merkten dass
es diesen bedarf an informationen
weiterhin gibt und zweite nachfrage dazu
noch vor wenigen tagen haben sie uns
hier persönlich wörtlich gesagt wir
stehen immer noch am anfang der anime
bild das jetzt nicht mehr sind wir jetzt
am ende
das war die pressekonferenz nicht mehr
brauchen wie gesagt hatte wir werden
wieder presse briefings machen wenn
entsprechender eine entsprechende anlass
besteht und mit diesem anlass daneben
auch entsprechender informationsbedarf
aus unserer sicht ansonsten machen wir
natürlich ganz normale pressearbeit sie
können ihre anfragen und ihren
informationsbedarf dann natürlich über
die ganz normalen üblichen wege
letztendlich bei uns stellen und wir
werden die natürlich dann auch
beantworten
wir stehen am anfang der pandemie und
ich habe aber auch gesagt auch an dieser
stelle dass das sehr lange dauern kann
das kann noch viele monate dauern und es
wird sich vermutlich ins nächste jahr
hinein ziehen die pandemie insgesamt und
all diese zeit werden wir ein gewisses
werden wir mit diesem virus zu tun haben
während er mit bekämpfungsmaßnahmen zu
tun haben werden wir versuchen und das
ist glaube ich jetzt ja insgesamt der
gesellschaftliche versuch dieses virus
und dieses geschehen so in den alltag
einzubauen dass wir damit umgehen können
dass wir eben lernen damit umzugehen
dass wir unser verhalten entsprechend
anpassen dass es ein verhalten ist dass
möglichst wenig übertragung erlaubt aber
eben gleichzeitig auch uns erlaubt ein
normales leben zu führen in einer das
ist das stichwort das schon mehrfach
genannt worden ist hat es auch schon
erwähnt in einer neuen normalität und
das geht natürlich dann auch für uns und
in diesem sinne beispiel sinkenden
fallzahlen und bei einem versuch der
adaptation an die neue normalität denke
ich dass es jetzt ein guter zeitpunkt
ist diese umstellung zu machen
nochmal zum ende erhalten
da können sie mich hören jetzt ich habe
eine frage die fußball bundesliga
startet wieder
ich weiß dass sport jetzt nicht hier
kein thema ist aber medizinisch gesehen
für wie wahrscheinlich halten sie denn
eine ansteckung auf dem spielfeld zum
beispiel bei einem zweikampf wenn es
eine unentdeckte kroner infektion bei
einem spieler gibt ja das mag ihn jetzt
komisch vorkommen aber ich hatte auch
gesagt das ist arbeitsschutz war das
eben fußball profis sind und ich hatte
mich dazu abschließend geäußert
die fangen eine infektion durch das all
experten sicher dazu geäußert inwiefern
beim tiefen einatmen beim schnellen
arten bei direkten körperkontakt ist
einfach medizinisch gesehen und das ist
ja dann doch auch ihr aufgabenbereich
eine ansteckungsgefahr nicht erhöht ist
also wie gesagt die kollegen von der
arbeitsschutz bereich die haben das
begutachtet die haben sich dazu geäußert
und ich werde jetzt nicht irgendwie
nicht dazu in irgendeiner anderen art
und weise äußern und glaube habe das
auch jetzt mehrfach deutlich gemacht
wir gehen zum handelsblatt vogelmann ich
habe eine frage zu den tests und den
kapazitäten das erinnert er immer wieder
gesagt wir müssen strategisch testen
wie sind die aktuellen zahlen wie ist
die eu wie hoch ist die test kapazität
jetzt aktuell wie viel davon werden
nicht genutzt und oder wurden nicht
genutzt
in den letzten tagen oder wochen je
nachdem welche zahlen sie haben und wozu
sollte diese überschüssige kapazität in
anführungsstrichen ihrer meinung nach
genutzt werden
ja also es ist so dass zurzeit eine test
kapazität von 960.000 also noch ein ganz
genau 164 1962 durchführbaren tests pro
woche in deutschland besteht und genutzt
wurden in der 18 kalenderwoche
317 1979 test also so viele sind
durchgeführt worden
dafür waren 12.000 in etwa positiv also
etwa 3,8 prozent also etwa ein drittel
der test kapazitäten wurden genutzt
wobei auch weiterhin es so ist dass die
test kapazitäten praktisch die kapazität
ist die die apparate durchführen können
aber wir haben auch von den knapp 175
laboren die uns rückmeldungen geben
hierzu dieser erfassung etwa ein viertel
der labore die letztendlich auch
schwierigkeiten haben verbrauchsmaterial
weiterhin zu beziehen wie vor
schwierigkeiten gibt es eben für
extraktion skript abtritt abstrich
kupfer und auch pipetten spitzen aber
ich denke dennoch wird es so sein dass
die test kapazität nicht ausgenutzt ist
zurzeit und das hat natürlich auch mit
den sinkenden fallzahlen zu tun
die test empfehlungen wie wir gegeben
haben und das sind die empfehlungen
müssen keine vorgaben oder vorschriften
die haben auch nichts mit
erstattungsregeln zu tun er statt da
wird an anderer stelle geregelt also die
empfehlung die wir gegeben haben sind
sehr sensitiv jeder der eine entspannten
oder symptomatik einer atemwegsinfektion
hat sollte getestet werden oder eben
auch wenn man kontakt natürlich hatte zu
einem infizierten oder wenn man eben
symptome hat und aus einem aus einem
bereich kommt wo risikogruppen leben und
darüber hinaus gibt es natürlich auch
die möglichkeiten das haben wir auch in
unserem papieren betont und es auch
jetzt nachzulegen lesen auf den papieren
auch asymptomatische personen zu testen
zum beispiel im ausbruchsgeschehen und
bei der kontaktperson nachverfolgung
auch in alten- und pflegeheim ist es
unter bestimmten bedingungen eben
sinnvoll und auch in krankenhäusern wenn
dort eben mit 19 patienten betreut
werden dann ist es natürlich auch unter
umständen sinnvoll die dass das personal
das dort tätig ist regelmäßig zu
beproben also all diese dinge sind ja
öffentlich und gesagt worden und aus
meiner sicht ist es nicht schlecht wenn
man eine gewisse reserve test kapazität
hat denn wir müssen natürlich auch damit
rechnen dass das gbr steigende
fallzahlen haben werden und dann wird
sich möglicherweise auch dieses
verhältnis von einem drittel
durchgeführter test kapazität sehr
schnell wieder ändern können gleichwohl
ist es auch so dass wir weiterhin
ermuntern sehr sensitiv und empfindlich
letztendlich dieser test durchzuführen
und ganz wichtig ist eben da auch die
ansprache der hausärztlichen und
kassenärztlichen versorgung das eben
dort auch diese tests durchgeführt
werden wenn eine entsprechende atemweg
symptomatik vorhanden ist das ist
natürlich immer ein interesse aller um
empfindlich fälle aufzudecken und dann
entsprechend die isolierung und die
kontaktpersonen nachverfolgung
durchführen zu können
wir gehen zur tagesschau herr k
guten tag
die maßnahmen werden überall
zurückgedreht die pressekonferenzen des
aktiven eingestellt ein großer teil der
hoheit geht an die landkreise und länder
die zeichen stehen alle auf entspannung
wenn ich das richtig verstehe stellt
sich mir die frage gehen sie davon aus
dass die epidemie in deutschland auch
mit diesen nun deutlich weniger
maßnahmen und einschränkungen unter
kontrolle gehalten werden kann und falls
ja warum also
ich möchte noch mal ganz klar sagen die
epidemie ist damit natürlich nicht zu
ende das virus ist noch in deutschland
wir haben das virus sehr substanziell
denke ich zurück gedrängt in den
vergangenen wochen auf ein level dass
die täglichen neu gemeldeten fälle um
die 1000 liegen zwischen 600 und 1300
diese 1300 ist jetzt auch die höchste
zahl in dieser woche gewesen und durch
die wochenenden gibt es auch immer
gewisse nachholeffekte das muss man
weiter beobachten dass sie
selbstverständlich keine entwarnung
weiterhin müssen die gesundheitsämter
müssen alle ebenen in dem im
gesundheitssystem weiterhin sehr wachsam
sein und die situation weiter beobachten
deshalb auch die der aufruf eben viel zu
testen und empfindlich zu testen
das ist ganz klar also eine entwarnung
bedeutet das nicht es bedeutet auch ein
gewisses risiko jetzt weitere
lockerungen zu machen das ist glaube ich
völlig klar
aber es ist eben auch klar auf der
anderen seite dass dieses virus nicht in
deutschland reduziert werden kann
das ist die meinung aller
wissenschaftler dass das vermutlich
nicht gelegen wird so dass wir mit
diesem virus leben müssen spätestens bis
ein impfstoff da ist das weiß aber
niemand ob und wann der kommt bzw eine
therapie die man möglicherweise auch zur
prophylaxe einsetzen kann
all das sind um gewisse faktoren wie auf
jeden fall noch wochen bis monate dauern
werden
und bis dahin eben einen weg zu finden
das virus zu kontrollieren auf diesem
niedrigen niveau
und trotzdem gesellschaftliches leben zu
haben das ist ja jetzt der ansatz der
gefunden worden ist oder der gegangen
werden soll
und ich glaube die die warnschilder die
sind ja an einstellen aufgestellt worden
von der politik und auch von den
wissenschaftlern und die müssen
natürlich auch beachtet werden
und ich glaube das ist ja auch jedem
bewusst dass das nur klappen kann wenn
man durch sein persönliches verhalten
durch seine verantwortungsbewusstsein
durch sei durch abstand halten durch das
tragen der maske in der in der
öffentlichkeit wenn man an ein personen
begegnet durch die hygienemaßnahmen dass
es nur dann gelingen kann
beides zu vereinbaren das virus zu
kontrollieren und eben eine
entsprechendes gesellschaftliches leben
führen zu können aber ich denke es ist
auch legitim diesen versuch jetzt zu
machen und die situation weiterhin zu
beobachten
wahrscheinlich nicht nur legitim sondern
auch erforderlich gesellschaftlich wir
gehen zur bloomberg news frau christen
wollen eine andere frage dazu nach ihrer
jetzigen schätzung wann erwarten sie
dass die zweite welle der epidemie in
deutschland treffen wird und welche
faktoren beeinflussen das auftreten
dieser zweiten welle am stärksten
also das kann ihnen niemand sagen ein
faktor den man natürlich überlegen muss
gibt es eine gewisse saisonalität auch
das haben wir hier schon besprochen
alle zeichen deuten darauf hin dass es
keine starken kein starken effekt der
saisonalität der sommermonate der
steigenden temperaturen auf die
übertragbarkeit dieses virus gibt
möglicherweise einen leichten effekt der
könnte sich dann verstärkt wieder im
herbst äußern so dass das sicherlich
eine zeit ist wo man noch mal genauer
hingucken muss aber es kann natürlich
schon sein dass auch vorher die
fallzahlen wieder steigen und wir eine
zweite welle bekommen nämlich dann wenn
das menschliche verhalten einfach sich
soweit wieder lockert das es zu
vermehrten übertragungen kommen und dass
eben auch noch deshalb nochmal der
dringende appell wir haben das alles
selbst in der hand ob und wann es diese
zweite welle geben wird und beeinflussen
können wir das zurzeit nicht durch
impfstoffe nicht durch medikamente
sondern einzig durch unser verhalten und
deswegen ist es ebenso wichtig dieses
verhalten auch entsprechend anzupassen
da ist viel passiert über die letzten
monate wir alle haben ja viel gelernt
was den umgang mit diesem virus angeht
was die umstellung unseres eigenen
verhaltens angeht
das kann man ja auch messen und dieses
verhalten nun in einem gleichgewicht zu
bringen mit den übertragen
das ist im grunde die herausforderungen
in den nächsten wochen und wir haben es
in der hand und ich bin auch
optimistisch dass es gelingen kann wenn
das wenn die leute ihr verhalten nicht
nicht anpassen dass die zweite welle
deutschland treffen könnte vor den
herbst dass man das schon im august
sehen könnte oder sogar vielleicht ja
das ist möglich das kann sein
wir gehen zu frau und wenn sie in der
weise noch die redaktion sorgen
angelika von hr-info ich wollte auch
noch mal nachfragen wieso jetzt diese
regelmäßigen presse briefings abgesagt
werden wo er jetzt durch die lockerungen
auch durchaus mit mehr neuinfektionen zu
rechnen ist wenn ich das richtig gesehen
haben gibt es ja jetzt auch schon
zumindest von den zahlen her männer
infektionen also heute um die 1300
gestern 900 montag 600 also die zahlen
steigen ja jetzt und gerade um sowas
einordnen zu können woher kommt das wäre
das ja wichtig also das würde ich nicht
so sehen dass die zahlen jetzt steigen
das kann man in diesem wochenverlauf
daraus nicht ziehen wenn sie sich die
kurve angucken dem aufgeteilt nach melde
datum auf unserem dashboard dann sieht
man ja immer diese sägezahn artigen
diesen sägezahn artigen verlauf mit
wenig meldungen um das wochenende herum
jetzt hatten wir auch noch einen freitag
als feiertag dazu da gibt es immer einen
einbruch an den meldezahlen und
regelmäßig ist es so dass am mittwoch
donnerstag die höchsten zahlen im
wochenverlauf zu verzeichnen sind
gleichwohl wenn man sich die woche
insgesamt anguckt und diese woche mit
der vorwoche vergleicht dann waren das
weiterhin noch fallende fallzahlen was
den was den verlauf angeht so dass ich
aus dieser aus diesem verlauf in der
woche an sich von montag bis jetzt dass
die zahlen gestiegen sind da kann man
noch keinen anstieg draus machen das
können wir eigentlich erst dann in der
nächsten woche beurteilen ob das 1 1
tatsächliche anstieg ist jetzt würde ich
vermuten
das ist dem normalen das meldeverhalten
im wochenverlauf widerspiegelt wie in
den wochen davor auch eine zur zweiten
frage wenn es tatsächlich dazu kommt
dass die fallzahlen wieder steigen und
sich ein neues dynamisches geschehen
entwickelt dann werden wir
selbstverständlich auch die presse
wieder informieren auch aktiv und wenn
es dann geboten scheint eben auch in mit
neuen presse briefings danke wir gehen
zur frau schmidt von radio münchen
schönen guten morgen saß cause 2 ist ein
corona assoziiertes virus und wie herr
thorsten bemerkte könnte es sein dass
wir in der bevölkerung bereits eine
gewisse immunität aufgebaut haben weil
wir uns durch andere coronaviren
immunisiert haben
der professor schade erstens wenn dieses
virus mutiert wie wir das von den vier
generationen kennen wie rasch muss eine
impfung dann auf den markt kommen
um dieses corona virus überhaupt noch
anzutreffen
und zweitens christian drosten äußerte
zur raschen entwicklung im märz mehrfach
und hier ein zitat wir müssen regularien
für impfstoffe außer kraft setzen
jetzt ist die firma biontech mit der
testung einer rna impfung am start bei
der der impfstoff im grunde erst im
körper des patienten hergestellt wird
von dessen eigenen zellen das ist eine
komplett neue methode wie beurteilen sie
das muss nicht gerade bei einer so neuen
technologie die absicherung in alle
richtungen vor allem auch für die
langzeitwirkungen besonders hoch gehängt
werden ja zunächst mal vielleicht zum
corona virus also jedes virus kann
mutieren herren a viren sowieso unter
den alien ist das korrupte sind die
korona wir noch viren die die relativ
wenig mutieren aber sie mutieren eben
auch es ist aber nicht so dass jede
mutation sofort eine änderung der
gefährlichkeit zur folge hat oder eine
änderung der immunität so dass
impfstoffe nicht mehr wirken können oder
vielleicht auch sogar
resistenz das gefundene medikamente
nicht mehr wirken können viele dieser
dieser mutationen sind so klein dass er
diese auswirkungen eben nicht haben
wir können das trotzdem messen wenn man
das virus sequenzieren oder die
erbsubstanz das virus sequenzieren wir
können das vor allen dingen nutzen um
letztendlich die den weg des virus
während einer infektion nachzuvollziehen
also es wird viel über mutationen ja
auch berichtet diese mutationen haben
bisher aber eben keine auswirkung auf
die gefährlichkeit des virus oder auf
die immunität des virus das ist wichtig
vor weg zu schicken wenn eine mutation
stattfinden würde die letztendlich zu
einem zu einer escape mutante von einem
impfstoff der noch gar nicht da ist
führen würde dann müsste man diesen
impfstoff anpassen
dafür gibt es aber mechanismen die
vorgedacht sind das kennen wir im grunde
von den influenza impfstoffen dann hat
man einen impfstoff konzept das vom
prinzip zugelassen ist wo man auch weiß
wie sicher das ist und dann kann man das
anpassen so was wäre grundsätzlich auch
für corona wären denkbar falls es denn
in der zukunft mal zu solchen gutachten
kommen könnte bisher wie gesagt gibt es
keinen hinweis darauf dass solche
mutanten vorkommen zur anderen frage das
ist ja eine frage der der impfstoff
regulation und dass das ist eine frage
die eigentlich das robert koch institut
nicht beantworten kann und auch nicht
beantworten sollte da ist unser
schwesterinstitut das paul ehrlich
institut für zuständig dass eben die
zulassung von impfstoffen reguliert und
eben auch hier dann impfstoffe mit
zulässt gemeinsam mit mit den
europäischen institutionen also so eine
frage die er doch sehr spezifisch ist da
würde ich sie bitten die anspach
jährlich in situ zu richten
ist es denn wirklich so dass die
impfstoffe vom paul-ehrlich-institut
noch einmal validiert werden oder reicht
es aus dass die firmen ihre testungen
veröffentlichen
ja sehen sie das ist eine frage wie kann
ihnen wirklich präzise vor allen dingen
das paul-ehrlich-institut beantworten
wir gehen zur story vom westdeutschen
rundfunk guten tag können sie mich hören
wollen sie also gut ich hab noch mal
eine frage zu der erweiterung des
kontaktverbot
es wurde jetzt festgestellt dass man in
zukunft sich nicht nur mit einer
einzelnen person im öffentlichen raum
treffen kann sondern mit einer ganzen
vermied anderen familie oder einem
ganzen anderen haushalt heißt das ich
suche mir jetzt eine familie oder ein
haushalt aus und mit denen darf ich mich
immer wieder mal treffen oder kann ich
nicht motors mit der einen familie und
dienst das mit dem anderen haushalt
treffen
ich kann das nicht richtig erkennen in
den formulierungen
letzteres wäre ja nicht so sind schon
also ich dass das kann ich ihnen zurzeit
nicht sagen das ist ja einen
rahmenbeschluss ein rahmenbeschluss von
allen 16 bundesländern gemeinsam mit der
bundesregierung und wie das dann genau
ausgestaltet wird das wird man jetzt in
den nächsten tagen in den entsprechenden
verordnungen der der länder sehen ich
gehe davon aus dass an dieser stelle
dann eine präzisierung stattfinden wird
so dass es da keine keine nachfrage mehr
geben kann ist zurzeit kann ich ihnen
das nicht beantworten was hätten sie
denn sinnvoll
das muss man auch über einen gewissen
zeitlichen verlauf sehen also auch da
muss man ja sagen wenn diese verordnung
jetzt wochen lang in kraft ist dann ist
es möglicherweise auch durchaus zu
vertreten dass man mit mehreren anderen
familien in kontakt tritt
auch das muss man ausgestalten und muss
man sich noch entsprechend vielleicht
praktikable wege überlegen dass das kann
ich im moment auch nicht präzise
beantworten wie das wie das dann laufen
kann
wir gehen zu planet interview herr ja
hören mich ja danke zwei fragen zum
einen die frage ist wurde nun in den
vergangenen monaten tausende menschen in
alten- und pflegeheim isoliert gibt es
für das lka jetzt schon eine evidenz
dass der nutzen durch diese isolation
größer ist als der schaden der damit für
diese menschen angerichtet wurde
und dann
hätte ich noch mal zwei tage das ist
also dann müssen müsste man jetzt ja
erfassen und das ist letztendlich mit
der mit daten noch nicht geschehen
welche nebenwirkungen sage ich mal von
diesem isolierung maßnahmen denn
tatsächlich auftreten
das wird man erst mit einer gewissen
verzögerung sehen können wie viel sage
ich mal depressionen zum beispiel sind
dadurch tatsächlich ausgelöst worden
solche zahlen kann ich ihnen zurzeit
nicht nennen und dann der zweite faktor
den man haben müsste und die man dann
untersuchen lässt er ist im grunde ja um
die effektivität der maßnahme an sich zu
beurteilen
verschiedene einrichtungen miteinander
vergleichen wo vielleicht schwerere oder
stringentere hygienemaßnahmen und
isolierung maßnahmen gemacht worden sind
als andere und die effektivität dieser
maßnahme dann für sich erstmal zu
beurteilen das sind alles untersuchungen
die noch kommen werden wo es zurzeit
noch keine daten zu gibt die man ins
verhältnis zueinander setzen könnte was
man natürlich sagen kann ist dass dort
wo dies das virus einen ausbruch
verursacht hat in den altenheimen zum
beispiel in den altenheimen oder auch
ein pfleger anderen pflegeeinrichtungen
mit mit vielen risikopatienten dass dort
natürlich der der impact dieses virus
ganz erheblich ist das hat natürlich
ganz erhebliche folgen für die anwohner
was schwere krankheitsverläufe und
sterbefälle betrifft ok und die zweite
frage werden auch herr wieder sagte vor
zwei tagen hier im briefing zitat ist
wird uns helfen bei der nächsten
grippewelle wenn die menschen die
abstandsregeln einhalten heißt es dass
wir sozusagen beim einsetzen der
nächsten grippewelle im spätherbst oder
winter dann auch wieder
großveranstaltungen flächendeckend
absagen in deutschland also würden sie
das empfehlen weil eben ja auf solchen
veranstaltungen indoor und outdoor
solche abstandsregeln gar nicht
eingehalten werden können
das ist ich möchte die frage andersherum
beantworten also wir werden ja
irgendwann wieder ob influenza oder
nicht influenza irgendwann werden wir
auch wieder groß veranstaltungen
durchführen und auch da gilt es
letztendlich einen weg zu finden wie man
eben groß veranstaltungen durchführen
kann
unter beachtung zumindest gewisse
abstandsregeln auch das ist ja denkbar
man muss ein stadium vielleicht nicht
mit 50.000 personen für füllen sondern
eben vielleicht nur mit der hälfte der
zuschauer sodass eben abstandsregeln
leichter einzuhalten sind
in den nächsten monaten das ist ja
entschieden worden wird es keine
großveranstaltung geben
ich sehe jetzt auch nicht wenn sie mich
so umfragen dass die nächste
influenzawelle ein ein träger sein
könnte um dann die großveranstaltungen
sofort wieder abzusagen was ich sie sehe
er in der mittelfristigen bis
langfristigen perspektive sind eben
großveranstaltungen die unter
veränderten bedingungen stattfinden wo
man eben hygieneregeln und
abstandsregeln dann eben doch anhalten
kann das halte ich andersrum ausgedrückt
sogar als eine für eine voraussetzung um
wieder groß veranstaltungen durchführen
zu können
solange das virus in deutschland
vorhanden ist als crooner virus wir
gehen zur pop times voraus ja gut morgen
also ich finde es sehr bedauerlich dass
die regelmäßigen presse briefings nicht
mehr stattfinden sollen
an dieser stelle möchte ich einfach die
gelegenheit nutzen ich auch meinen der
runde auch bei den kollegen für ihre
fragen zu beantworten
ich denke wir konnten uns der regelmäßig
mit gebündelten fragen und antworten
bereichern
meine frage an sie professor schade in
der korona daten spende blog ist jetzt
diese ruhepuls karte von deutschland
aufgeführt welche erkenntnisse gibt es
dazu und ich habe gelesen in zukunft
soll die tägliche schritt zahl der
teilnehmer untersucht werden was
versprechen sie sich von den angaben und
vor auf lassen diese rückschlüsse ziehen
also man sind werden auch in der phase
sage ich mal
das system einzureichen und die dass das
ziel der der soldaten spendet app ist ja
am ende eine fahrkarte zu haben und
diese fieber karte möglichst auch zu
benutzen dann um form vorwarnungen zu
machen und die erhöhte körpertemperatur
soll eben über den pulsschlag abgeleitet
werden und dazu muss man erst mal wissen
was ist denn der normale pulsschlag in
deutschland wenn man das mal so platt
formulieren darf im durchschnitt und das
ist eben jetzt diese diese karte mit der
mit der angabe der herzfrequenz die sie
jetzt in dem blog finden können das ist
also die erste stufe der eichung und
dann gibt es natürlich auch noch
aktivitäten die den pulsschlag
beeinflussen
und um diese diesen nächsten
einflussfaktor beurteilen zu können
dafür ist dann letztendlich diese
schritt zählung war die ja auch einfluss
auf den puls hat und dann wird man
hoffentlich sehen das ist die die das
ist der sinn dieser dieser einreichung
dass es unterschiede gibt zwischen einer
pulsfrequenz erhöhung die mit einer mit
mit körperlicher aktivität einhergeht
und einer pulsfrequenz erhöhung die
durch eine erhöhung der körpertemperatur
kommt das ist ja erstmal naheliegend
körpertemperatur erhöhung wird er sage
ich mal dauerhafter zu einer
pulsfrequenz erhöhung führen vielleicht
auch nachts während eine körperliche
aktivität er zu einem krieg führen wird
aber um das genau voneinander
unterscheiden zu können auch wie es dann
aussieht auf dieser karte im mass bild
dafür ist eben an dieser zweite schritt
erforderlich und es zieht es am ende
erhöhte körpertemperatur sprich fieber
auf diesen karten darstellen zu können
vielen dank so wir sind jetzt am ende
angelangt und bedanken uns noch mal ganz
herzlich für ihre fragen und für ihre
teilnahme und vielleicht bis irgendwann
bei einem einzelnen briefing bis dahin
bleiben sie gesund
vielen dank auf wiedersehen